Empecemos con un repaso del sistema decimal
ya que entender el sistema decimal nos ayudará
a entender el sistema binario.
Si consideramos el número 234,
dos tres cuatro, podemos decir que el
4 está en la posición de las unidades,
el 3 está en la posición de las decenas, mientras
que el 2 está en la posición de las centenas.
Esto significa que este número es igual
a 2 por 100, más 3 por 10, más 4 por 1.
Esto es igual a 234.
Ahora bien, también
podemos decir que la posición de las
unidades es 10 elevado a la potencia 0,
la posición de las decenas es 10 elevado
a la potencia 1, y la posición de las
centenas es 10 elevado a la potencia 2.
Si agregamos otra posición por aquí
tendríamos 1000 y eso sería lo mismo
que 10 elevado a la tercera potencia.
Cada posición representa una potencia de 10
es por esto que le llamamos sistema decimal.
Viene de 10 en latín.
Para saber qué número estamos viendo simplemente
miramos el dígito que está en esa posición y
lo multiplicamos por el valor de esa posición.
Entonces un 1 aquí será uno por mil,
más 234 y este es el sistema decimal.